This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。保证是真人。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《艰难成长的教训》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。这个节目聚焦于黑男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都感觉不太安全进行的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起探讨这些。有多少男人背负着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，听听如何吸取
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
以艰难的方式，在AHA电台应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了一大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一面成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即TWO.%，可在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. Now, there are a lot of things that cause us, I would say, a great deal of stress and unhappiness in our 20s. And a lot of it is beyond our control. This is naturally
我们总是说要相信你的闺蜜们。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《相信闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》（The Girlfriends. Trust me, babe）。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个探讨我们在20多岁时经历的一些重大生活变化与转型，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客，新听友们，老听友们，无论你们身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你们能回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们将一如既往地剖析20多岁的心理学。如今，有很多事情，可以说是让我们在20多岁时感到巨大的压力和不快乐。其中很多事情是我们无法控制的。这自然是
a decade where we feel extremely lost. Things are very much up in the air. But I would say a fair amount of our occasional misery and our self-doubt comes down to things that we can change when we kind of examine our mindset and how we trade ourselves and how we acknowledge our wins, our successes, our best attributes. What we're talking about today is self-comparsion, namely why it is that social comparison steals so much joy from us, but also how we can learn to stop tearing ourselves down by constantly measuring ourselves against others, by constantly looking at their careers, at their relationships, at their clothes, their body, their success, their financial situation, and feeling like we are lacking. I think comparison is one of those really hard
一个让我们感到极度迷茫的十年。一切都充满了不确定性。但我可以说，我们偶尔的痛苦和自我怀疑，很大程度上归结于我们可以改变的事情，只要我们审视一下自己的心态，看看我们如何对待自己，如何认可我们的赢面、成功和最佳特质。我们今天要讨论的是自我比较，也就是为什么社会比较会夺走我们那么多的快乐，以及我们如何学会停止通过不断拿自己与他人作比较，通过不断审视他们的职业、他们的关系、他们的衣服、他们的身材、他们的成功、他们的财务状况来贬低自己，并觉得自己有所欠缺。我认为比较是作为人类非常艰难的一部分，对吧？
parts about being human, right? I find it so fascinating that as a species we have all the critical thinking skills in the world, we can solve some of humanity's greatest problems. Our brains quite literally contain millions of neural connections. And yet we choose to use them in ways that hurt our own feelings in ways that harm us more than they benefit us. And one of those ways is by constantly comparing ourselves to others and coming up short, it's like self-imposed psychological torture in so many ways. But on another level, sometimes we don't feel like we can stop. We just never feel good enough. And so we use social comparison to reinforce that, perhaps as a form of self-sabotage. If our self-esteem is already in the dumps, we sometimes do things that don't serve us because
我发现这太迷人了，作为人类物种，我们拥有世界上所有的批判性思维技能，我们能够解决人类面临的一些最伟大的问题。我们的大脑字面意思上包含数百万个神经连接。然而，我们却选择以伤害自己感情的方式来使用它们，以对我们弊大于利的方式来伤害我们。其中一种方式就是不断地将自己与他人进行比较，然后觉得自己不够好，这在很多方面就像是自加的心理折磨。但在另一个层面，有时我们觉得无法停下来。我们总是觉得自己不够好。于是我们利用社会比较来强化这一点，也许这是一种自我破坏的形式。如果我们的自尊心已经跌入谷底，我们有时就会做一些对自己没有益处的事，因为
we think that we deserve to feel bad. We do things like procrastinating or binge drinking or self-isolating or looking into the lives of other people and fantasizing about how much better things would be if we were more like them. I think this just perpetuates the cycle and it steals a lot of our joy. We're particularly prone to this in our 20s of course because our identity already feels quite unstable and there is a great deal of insecurity amongst people in this generation and insecurity that stems from uncertainty about the future and uncertainty about our place in this world. From an evolutionary perspective, some psychologists would also argue that we actually have an innate
我们觉得自己就该感到难过。我们会做一些事情，比如拖延、暴饮暴食、自我隔离，或者窥探别人的生活，并幻想如果我们更像他们的话，生活会有多好。我认为这只会延续这种循环，并剥夺了我们很多的快乐。当然，我们在20多岁时特别容易受到这种心态的影响，因为我们的身份认同本身就显得相当不稳定，而且这一代人之中存在着很大的不安全感，这种不安全感源于对未来的不确定性以及对我们在世界上所处地位的不确定性。从进化的角度来看，一些心理学家也会认为，我们实际上具有一种与生俱来的
tendency to compare ourselves to others because in this way we learn what we might be doing wrong, but also how to fit in. So in that way, it serves this social purpose. Now, this idea was first introduced back in the 1950s by a social psychologist known as Leon Fessinger. If you are a bit of a psychology geek or a trivia master, you'll recognize that name because he is also responsible for the term cognitive dissonance. But Leon, he assumed that back when we roamed the savannah in tribes, when we were mere hunter-gatherers, comparing ourselves to others, conferred a survival advantage by providing information about our relative position within a group. As a result, this helped us assess what kind of resources we had access to, how we were kind of like squaring up
倾向，喜欢将自己与他人作比较，因为通过这种方式，我们能了解到自己可能哪里做错了，以及如何融入群体。所以从这个意义上说，它服务于这样一个社会目的。现在，这个观点最早是在20世纪50年代由一位名叫莱昂·费斯廷格（Leon Fessinger）的社会心理学家提出的。如果你有点像心理学极客或者琐事达人，你会认出这个名字，因为他也提出了“认知失调”这个词。但莱昂假设，早在我们在大草原上以部落形式漫游、当我们仅仅是猎人采集者的时候，与他人作比较可以通过提供我们在群体中相对位置的信息，来赋予我们生存优势。因此，这帮助我们评估了我们可以获得什么样的资源，我们是如何与他人进行
compared to others, what other people had that we lacked. It also helped us conform because we could look and observe how others were behaving and adapt our own behavior accordingly, meaning that we were less likely to be kicked out of the group because we were doing everything right, because we were basing our behavior on the norm that we saw projected by others. So we were more likely to be accepted. We were more likely to learn from other people in the group. And we were more likely to essentially survive. In that way, I think that social comparison also acted as a form of validation and personal reassurance, both back in the day and also these days, right? Like, if, you're If Wendy from down the street is wearing double denim and I am too, well, I must be doing
比较的，其他人拥有而我们缺乏的是什么。这也帮助我们融入群体，因为我们可以观察别人的行为并相应地调整我们自己的行为，这意味着我们被踢出群体的可能性更小，因为我们做的一切都是对的，因为我们的行为是基于别人所展现出的规范。所以我们更有可能被接纳。我们更有可能向群体中的其他人学习。并且我们基本上更有可能生存下来。从这个意义上说，我认为社会比较也充当了一种验证和个人安心的形式，无论是在过去还是在今天，对吧？比如，如果街那头的温迪（Wendy）穿着双层牛仔，而我也穿着，那说明我肯定做对了
something right. Or at least I have like an ally in this. We re-assure ourselves that we're not doing anything that's too ghastly or too against what people expect from us. Or, you know, if your good friend Dave, like took a gap here and still ended up with a great job, by comparing yourself to him, you feel like you can do that as well. We use others as an example to assure us that we are on the right path, that what we are doing will be accepted because somebody else is doing it, but also we use social comparison as a form of aspiration and sometimes even motivation. I think regardless of the purpose, there might be some quote unquote benefits. It can also make us feel pretty horrific when it goes untamed.
某些事。或者至少在这件事上我有了一个同盟。我们自我安慰，确信自己没有做什么太可怕的事情，也没有做什么太违背人们对我们期望的事。或者，你知道，如果你的好朋友戴夫（Dave）休了一年的间隔年，最后还找到了一份不错的工作，通过把他和自己作比较，你会觉得你也能做到这一点。我们以他人为榜样，向自己保证我们正走在正确的道路上，我们所做的事情会被接受，因为别人也在这样做，但同时我们也把社会比较当作一种抱负，有时甚至是动力。我认为无论出于何种目的，它可能确实有一些所谓的益处。但如果任其发展，它也会让我们感觉糟糕透顶。
I think also compared to our ancestors, which is what Leon Festinger based his theory on, right, we now have so many more opportunities to compare, compared to those people back then. We are exposed to, firstly, just a lot more people in our communities and in our environment compared to the small tribes that he was operating his beliefs on. And we also have social media, which means that at any stage, you can jump online and find the perfect example of somebody who is going to make you feel. feel bad about yourself. So for the most part, it can really give rise to a lot of feelings of jealousy or competition, which ends up harming our relationships and sadly how we treat ourselves and how we
我认为，与我们的祖先（这也是莱昂·费斯廷格理论的基础）相比，我们现在拥有更多与他人比较的机会，远超过去那些人。首先，与他当初构建理论时所处的小部落相比，我们社区和环境中接触到的人要多得多；其次，我们还有社交媒体，这意味着在任何阶段，你都可以上网找到一个完美的榜样，让你对产生自卑感。
treat others. It can make us feel a lot less grateful for what we do have because someone out there in the world is always going to have more. And as a result, we never feel quite satisfied because we're in this habitual spiral of chronic comparison. It is the classic idea that the grass is always greener on the other side. That is a tailor's oldest time, but something that I think contains an equal amount of truth is that the grass is actually greener where you water it. The ultimate kind of antidote to social comparison is feeling confident enough in what you're building and what you're doing and spending more time nurturing these parts of you than being distracted by other people's progress. That is something I'm definitely working on in my own life, but I'm also learning
因此，在大多数情况下，它确实会引发许多嫉妒或竞争的情绪，最终损害了我们的人际关系，可悲的是，也损害了我们对待自己和对待他人的方式。它会让我们对我们实际拥有的东西感到不那么感激，因为世界上总会有人拥有更多。结果，我们从未真正感到满足，因为我们陷入了慢性比较的习惯性漩涡中。这是一个经典的观点，即“邻家的草总是更绿”。这是一个历久弥新的老道理，但我认为同样包含真理的是，草其实长在你浇水的地方。克服社会比较的终极解药，是对你正在构建的事业和正在做的事情感到足够的自信，并将更多的时间花在滋养这些自我部分上，而不是被别人的进展所分散注意力。这是我自己在生活中绝对在努力做到的事情，但我也在学习
that when social comparison is used wisely, it can also be used to our advantage. If we switch from using social comparison as a form of like self-sabotage and trying to hurt our own feelings to an opportunity to really take stock of our lives and what we're actually grateful for, but also what we want to improve, sometimes it's rather useful. So today we're going to talk about five tips I have for controlling the temptation to compare, how to stop comparing yourself to others, or maybe more. A better way to put that is how to keep the parts of social comparison that benefit you and say goodbye to the other aspects. So we have a lot to talk about today, a lot to cover. Of course, a lot of fascinating psychology.
当明智地使用社会比较时，它也可以为我们所用。如果我们从将社会比较作为一种自我破坏的形式、试图伤害自己的感情，转变为借此真正审视我们的生活以及我们真正感激的是什么，同时也是我们想要改进的地方，有时它还是相当有用的。所以今天我们将讨论我控制比较诱惑的五个小建议，如何停止将自己与他人作比较，或者也许更确切地说，一个更好的说法是，如何保留社会比较中有益的部分，而对其他方面说再见。所以我们今天要谈论很多，要涵盖很多内容。当然，还有许多迷人的心理学知识。
So without further ado, let's get into it. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an essay. escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you
废话不多说，我们切入正题。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾真正相信种子油天生具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你
will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What? The hell does George Bush got to do a little count? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
将在另一面成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即TWO percent，可在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMAs上拍了金·卡戴珊（Lil Kim）的胸部两下吗？还是当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。什么？乔治·布什跟金·卡戴珊到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at it）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利希（Alex English）。
Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
每一集，我们都会挑选一个时刻，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，他大谈80年代的可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不只是因为可卡因。我随时都可以谈论可卡因，只是为了让你们知道。我是说，马克，到了这个时候，这已经是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里有一条主线了。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在台面上了。谢谢你把话说完。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade.
是的。我认为没有比这更重要的一年了，对黑人而言。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难成长的教训》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了十多年的
of my own experience in the middle health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
我在心理健康领域的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的有。特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们还在继续追逐。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
而且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在盯着记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你觉得在这个世界上做一个好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, our Heart Radio app.
绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的只是出于本心地去当一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯（Keer Gaines），在我的新播客《艰难成长的教训》（Learn the Hardway）中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的iHeart Radio应用程序。
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct?
搜索“Learn the Hardway”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露出她谎言中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的诉讼战，旨在证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was bold.
我篡改过一次测试。这动用了一大批互联网侦探才破了案。我希望人们能看到他们的税款都被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露出了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯皮安（Greg Lespian）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。
alone. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. The easiest way to let something control you is to ignore it and suppress it. I think any time we try too hard to not do something to, you know, keep our hands behind our back,
只有。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。让某事控制你的最简单方法就是忽视它并压制它。我认为任何时候，当我们过于努力不去刻意做某事，为了，你知道的，把手背在身后，
that just really hands over the microphone and it amplifies our insecurities. Because we feel like that if we were to set this thing free, if we were to allow ourselves to compare ourselves to others as much as we want, it would give it all the power and we are so scared of that reality that we actually end up focusing more on the possibility of that happening as a result. So what we really didn't want to happen becomes inevitable because we avoided it for too long and we gave it power over ourselves. It might sound counterintuitive, but if you want to reduce the negative effects of social
那实际上只是把麦克风交了出去，放大了我们的不安全感。因为我们觉得，如果我们把这件事释放出来，如果我们允许自己随心所欲地将自己与他人进行比较，它就会获得全部的力量，而我们对那种现实感到如此害怕，以至于我们最终反而更加关注这种可能性发生的概率。所以我们真正不想发生的事情变得不可避免，因为我们逃避得太久，并赋予了它对我们的控制力。这听起来可能与直觉相反，但如果你想减少社会
comparison, you kind of have to give yourself permission to compare yourself to others whenever you would like. So this is rule one. Don't unfollow, don't suppress, accept your need to compare and expand on your comparison. So let me explain. I'm going to admit that in a past episode
比较的负面影响，你多少得给自己许可，每当你想将自己与他人进行比较时，就大胆去做。所以这是第一条规则。不要取消关注，不要压抑，接受你的比较需求，并扩展你的比较。让我解释一下。我得承认，在过去的一期
I did on social comparison, I gave some advice that I no longer believe in, particularly in regards to social media. So I think this episode came out a couple years ago and at the time my advice was to unfollow the people who made you feel bad. That woman with the better body than you, with the lavish lifestyle, the millions of followers, the person who was traveling to the places that you really wanted to go to whilst you were
关于社会比较的节目中，我给了一些我不再相信的建议，特别是关于社交媒体的。所以我想那期节目是几年前发布的，当时的建议是取消关注那些让你感觉不好的人。那个身材比你好、生活奢华、拥有百万粉丝的女人，那个去你想去的地方旅行的人，而你却
busy working your 9 to 5, if they trigger your social comparison, avoid it. Avoid exposure, unfollow, there we go, you're fixed. Your social comparison is no longer there because you're not experiencing it. I think I had a rather immature viewpoint back then, and I was trying to get the science to fit what I wanted to believe when honestly all the psychology really disagrees with me on that. Yes, there are some people you don't need to engage with on social media or in real life. But if you really want to gain power over your social comparison, you need to realize that these people are not a threat.
忙着做朝九晚五的工作，如果他们触发了你的社会比较，那就避开。避免接触，取消关注，好了，你被治愈了。你的社会比较不再存在了，因为你没有体验它。我想我当时的想法相当幼稚，我试图让科学去迎合我想要相信的东西，而老实说，所有的心理学都不同意我的这种观点。是的，有些人在社交媒体上或现实生活中你不需要与之互动。但如果你真的想重新掌控你的社会比较，你需要意识到这些人并不是威胁。
Their brilliance, their luck, their successes and your own are not mutually exclusive just because they're doing really well for themselves doesn't mean you can't feel good about what you have. If we unfollow anyone who makes us uncomfortable or who we feel jealous of, we end up in an echo chamber of only engaging with people who we don't see as a threat. And that really comes down to a classic form of avoidance, turning away from things that make us uncomfortable, instead of engaging with them and learning how to make them. and learning how to manage our feelings towards something that make us feel bad.
他们的才华、他们的运气、他们的成功与你自己的并不是排他的，仅仅因为他们过得很好，并不意味着你不能对你所拥有的感到高兴。如果我们取消关注任何让我们感到不舒服或让我们感到嫉妒的人，我们最终会陷入一个回音室，只与那些我们不认为具有威胁的人互动。这其实归根结底是一种经典的逃避形式，也就是转身背离那些让我们感到不舒服的事情，而不是去面对它们，并学习如何处理。去学习如何管理我们对那些让我们感觉糟糕的事情的感受。
I think in that space, with this perspective, we give our social comparison the power that it wants, meaning that yes, we will inevitably be exposed to someone who is doing better than us, who is making more money than us, who is absolutely crushing it. Whatever it is, it just isn't a big deal anymore. I think suppressing a bad feeling doesn't lessen its sting. It doesn't make it go away. The root cause, which is most likely your sense of insecurity, is still there. It just makes us less prepared or emotionally strong to deal with feeling unpresent when inevitably this person will come along, right?
我认为在那种空间里，带着这种视角，我们赋予了社会比较它所渴望的力量，这意味着，是的，我们不可避免地会接触到那些比我们过得好、比我们赚得多、或者各方面都极其优秀的人。无论是什么，这都不再是什么大不了的事情了。我认为压抑不好的感觉并不能减轻它的刺痛感。它不会让它消失。根本原因，很可能是你的不安全感，依然存在。它只会让我们在不可避免地遇到这样的人时，在心理上更没有准备，也缺乏情感上的坚韧来应对这种不适，对吧？
Like we just live behind a wall. We just never challenge ourselves. Instead, when you feel like there is that siren call to compare yourself, I'm going to say the thing that you probably least expect me to say, let yourself do it, but then expand on your comparison. For example, if you see someone on LinkedIn who just had a huge promotion and she's your age, you went to university together, her career is taken off, yours has kind of stalled. Yes, you can get upset. You can let yourself feel really shitty and assume that her success says something about
就像我们只是活在一堵墙后面。我们从来不挑战自己。相反，当你觉得有那种想要进行比较的警报响起时，我要说一句你可能最意想不到的话：让自己去做，然后拓展你的比较。例如，如果你在领英（LinkedIn）上看到有人刚刚获得了大晋升，她和你同龄，你们一起上过大学，她的事业腾飞了，而你的却有些停滞不前。是的，你可以感到不安。你可以让自己感觉真的很糟糕，并假设她的成功说明了
yours. But you can also add on to those judgments. So I'm going to give you a new example of what this sounds like. Adding on to our judgments that come from our need to compare basically shows us that our initial thought around what this person has that we don't is not the full picture. So for example, with this woman you see on LinkedIn, right? What you can say is this person is doing so well
你的情况。但你也可以对这些判断进行补充。所以我将为你提供一个新的例子，听起来会是这样的。补充我们因比较需求而产生的判断，基本上会向我们展示，我们最初对这个人拥有而我们没有的东西的看法并不是全貌。因此，举个例子，对于你在领英上看到的这个女人，对吧？你可以说的是，这个人做得很好，
and so am I. We just have different paths. I'm so jealous of what they're achieving. and I'll get there one day as well. I wish I had what she had. And it's great because I already have so much, so I'm so close. Her body is like so amazing and so beautiful. And so is mine.
我也一样。我们只是走了不同的路。我很嫉妒她所取得的成就。有一天我也会达到那个高度。我希望我能拥有她所拥有的。这很棒，因为我已经拥有了许多，所以我离目标很近了。她的身材是那么惊艳、那么美丽。我也是。
How amazing. The reason this works is that you don't scold yourself for comparing and therefore make it feel taboo or give it power. You just make your judgments more nuanced and you don't let them only take on a negative spin. On that note of LinkedIn and career comparison, let's talk about why social comparison seems to be impacting us so much more nowadays. Social media means that we are experiencing an insane level of information overload,
太棒了。这之所以有效，是因为你没有为进行比较而责备自己，从而使其成为禁忌或赋予其力量。你只是让你的判断变得更加细腻，不让它们只带有负面的色彩。借着领英和职业比较这个话题，让我们谈谈为什么社会比较在今天似乎对我们产生了如此大的影响。社交媒体意味着我们正在经历疯狂的信息过载，
whereby at any moment, you can be exposed to the lives of hundreds, if not thousands, of people. All you have to do is open your phone and you are going to see a highlight reel of everybody's lives, all the things that they know will get them likes, all the pictures that will match their aesthetic. It really warps our sense of what is normal, especially because social media was built to be performative. And when we get so much about information about the world, about trends, about what we should be doing, about what's cool, from social media, that means that our view of what is normal becomes quite skewed. So that brings me to rule number two. Keep your judgments realistic.
在任何时刻，你都可能接触到成百上千甚至上万人的人生。你所需要做的就是打开手机，然后你会看到每个人的高光时刻，所有他们知道能获得点赞的事情，所有符合他们审美风格的照片。它真的扭曲了我们对什么是正常的感知，尤其是因为社交媒体生来就是为了表演而建的。当我们从社交媒体上获取如此多关于世界、关于潮流、关于我们应该做什么、关于什么是酷的信息时，这就意味着我们对什么是正常的看法变得相当扭曲。这就引出了我的第二条规则。保持你的判断现实。
I know I sound like a broken record, but truly from somebody who does this themselves, I'll admit it, everything you see online is curated. Everything I post online, I think about a million times. I'm not posting like the random screenshots of like where my Uber is. I'm not posting like the photo I took of my Wi-Fi password. on like the back of the modem or like all the rubbish that I need to get collected. Even the videos you see of people who are complaining or tired or sad or going through a breakup or a setback, whatever it is, that is still not the full picture and it's often very strategic because we know that that kind of content, that vulnerable content, draws people in,
我知道我听起来像个碎碎念的复读机，但真心实意地讲，作为一个自己也这样做的人，我得承认，你在网上看到的一切都是经过精心策划的。我在线上发布的每件事，我都思考了上百万次。我不会发布诸如我的优步在哪里之类的随机截图。我不会发布诸如我拍的调制解调器背面的Wi-Fi密码照片，或者我需要清理的所有垃圾。甚至你看到的那些关于人们抱怨、疲惫、伤心、经历分手或挫折的视频，无论是什么，那仍然不是全貌，而且通常具有很强的策略性，因为我们知道这种内容、那种脆弱的内容会吸引人，
but it's still not real. It's still not the full picture. In that way we often comparing ourselves to a reality that doesn't even exist, not even for the person who was advertising it as such. It's why I'm such a big fan of those influencers or those pages that do post the unposed gym shots, who do post their messy homes, and their unblemished skin, and they're just everyday life. I think it's so comforting to see somebody who was breaking like the fourth wall of the internet, who was literally looking at you and going, this is not real. This is not real. None of this is real. And yet, you are basing your perceptions of your own life on someone else's sugar-coded version that they post online. Even in our real lives, even in like our everyday
但这仍然不是真的。它仍然不是全貌。通过这种方式，我们常常拿自己去和一个甚至根本不存在的现实进行比较，哪怕对于那些以此进行宣传的人来说也是如此。这就是为什么我如此喜欢那些发布未修饰健身照、发布他们凌乱的家、没有瑕疵的皮肤、展示他们日常生活的主播或账号。我觉得看到有人打破互联网的“第四堵墙”，直视着你并说“这不是真的。这不是真的。这一切都不是真的”是一件非常欣慰的事。然而，你却在根据别人发布在网上的加糖美化版本来构建你对自己生活的看法。即使在现实生活中，甚至在我们日常的
interactions with people, no one is coming out and saying exactly how they were feeling. No one is fessing up to half of the emotions that they're trying to manage. their insecurities, you know, the time that they spend alone, the fears, the doubts, the fights, I just think that it's good to remind yourself that it's not the truth. Keep that in mind. This brings me to rule number three, do things for you first, and sometimes for you only. Unhealthy social comparison can be a huge time-waster because it makes us doubt our own decisions and our path and therefore kind of keeps us in this loop.
人际交往中，也没有人会直言不讳地表达他们确切的感受。没有人会坦白他们试图应对的一半情绪。他们的不安全感，你知道的，他们独处的时间，恐惧，怀疑，争吵，我只是觉得提醒自己这不是真相是件好事。把这一点记在心里。这就引出了我的第三条规则，首先为自己做事，有时只为自己做事。不健康的社会比较可能是巨大的时间浪费，因为它让我们怀疑自己的决定和道路，从而让我们陷入这种循环中。
us stuck because we spend so much time thinking about what other people are thinking rather than actually just doing. I think that comes from this weird realization we have that the fact that we are comparing ourselves to others means that people are comparing themselves to us and they're measuring themselves up against our actions and our lives. So we better put on a really good show, right? This makes us quite insecure, I think, because we want to impress them. So we get stuck in trying to do things perfectly or according to what we think others want or will find aesthetic or attractive or worthwhile. And a lot of that stems from a sense of self-doubt that if we were to come out and just do what we would want to do to be authentic, that that might not be accepted.
让我们陷入困境，因为我们花太多时间思考别人在想什么，而不是真正地去行动。我认为这源于我们意识到一个奇怪的现象：既然我们将自己与他人进行比较，这就意味着人们也在将自己与我们进行比较，并在用我们的行为和生活来衡量自己。所以我们最好把戏演好，对吧？我认为这让我们相当没有安全感，因为我们想给他们留下深刻印象。因此，我们陷入了试图把事情做到完美，或者按照我们认为别人想要的、或者会觉得美观、有吸引力、有价值的方式去做的泥潭中。这其中很大一部分源于一种自我怀疑：如果我们走出来，只做我们想要做的事以求真实，那么这种真实可能不会被接受。
I like to use the example of choosing an outfit in the morning, right? Like not a huge risk, not a huge task, not groundbreaking. If you didn't think about what others were thinking or didn't pay much attention to, how they might be comparing themselves to you, you would wear whatever you wanted. You would pick up the first thing you saw, regardless of whether your top matched your pants, which matched your shoes. And if you were, you know, not thinking about other people's opinions, you would be ready out the door in five minutes. In contrast, if you are contemplating the judgments and the opinions of others trying to anticipate their thoughts and their feelings towards you, suddenly,
我喜欢用早上挑选衣服来举例，对吧？这不是什么巨大的风险，不是什么重大的任务，也不是开创性的事。如果你不考虑别人怎么想，或者不太关注他们可能会如何拿自己跟你作比较，你就会穿任何你想穿的衣服。你会拿起看到的穿的第一件衣服，不管你的上衣是否搭配你的裤子，裤子是否搭配你的鞋子。如果你，你知道的，不考虑别人的意见，你可以在五分钟内收拾好出门。相反，如果你在琢磨别人的判断和意见，试图预测他们对你的想法和感受，突然之间，
every choice takes on a whole new level of gravity. You start putting yourself in the mind of every person you walk past, the person that you're going to meet, the stranger your own age. The focus on what other people might be thinking about you makes every decision take so much longer. And it all derives from social comparison and realizing that there is this weird mind game going on between everybody where we're looking at others and they're looking at us trying to figure out what's cool, what's normal, what we should be doing. If you want to beat social comparison, go with your gut instinct. Don't fall into the game of thinking about what other people want from you. What do you want? If you want to post that photo on social media, that video, that TikTok,
每一个选择都带有全新的严肃性。你开始把自己代入你擦肩而过的每一个人、你要见的人、你同龄的陌生人的心中。对别人可能怎么看你的关注，让每一个决定都花费更长的时间。这一切都源于社会比较，并且意识到每个人之间都在进行着一场奇怪的心理游戏，我们在看着别人，而他们在看着我们，试图弄清楚什么是酷、什么是正常、我们应该做什么。如果你想战胜社会比较，跟着你的直觉走。不要陷入去思考别人对你有什么期望的游戏中。你想要什么？如果你想在社交媒体上发布那张照片、那个视频、那个TikTok，
don't question, just do it. You want to wear that outfit you like that you don't think is like trendy or stylish. Don't think. Just put it on. You want to buy those weird shoes because you really like them? Go ahead. You want to go to the gym in your sports bra. Even though your body doesn't look like hers or doesn't look like his or those shorts you think other people might have a problem with, feel the fear of judgment and do it anyway. People's opinions are their problem, not yours. If they want to spend their time and like, let's be honest, their finite, precious energy, making themselves feel better by looking at you and putting you down, that is their burden to bear. The antidote to social comparison is authenticity, and it's a muscle that you have to build.
不要怀疑，直接发。你想穿那件你喜欢的、但不觉得那么潮流或时尚的衣服吗？别多想。直接穿上。你想买那些奇怪的鞋子因为你真的很喜欢它们吗？去吧。你想穿着运动内衣去健身房。尽管你的身材看起来不像她，或者看起来不像他，或者那些你觉得别人可能会有异议的短裤，去感受审判的恐惧，依然去做。别人的意见是他们的问题，而不是你的。如果他们想把时间和（让我们老实说吧）他们有限的、宝贵的精力花在通过看着你并贬低你来让自己感觉更好上，那是他们需要承担的负担。社会比较的解药是真实性，这是一块你需要建立的肌肉。
Social comparison by nature asks us to converge to the norm to prevent sticking out as an outlier, to do what others are doing so that we're never the one sticking out in the crowd, we're never the one who's going to be judged. So the way to beat that is to do the absolute opposite. If there is something you want to do, do it. And you'll soon find that as you adjust to this new mindset, your urge to compare will start to fade. Because the information that you're getting from others' lives
社会比较本质上要求我们向规范靠拢，以防止作为局外人脱颖而出，去做别人正在做的事情，这样我们就永远不会是人群中那个特立独行的人，永远不会是那个将被评判的人。所以战胜它的方法就是做完全相反的事情。如果有你想做的事，就去做。你很快会发现，当你适应这种新心态时，你想要比较的冲动就会开始消退。因为你从别人的生活中获得的信息
and whether they're better or worse than yours, whether they're judging you, their opinions, it doesn't really matter anymore. It doesn't serve you because you're coming to the table with the perspective of I'm just going to do it. I'm just going to be the person I want to be. I'm going to act the way I want to act. This is who I am.
——无论是比你的更好还是更糟，他们是否在评判你，他们的意见——其实已经不重要了。它对你没有任何用处，因为你带着这样的视角来到这里：我只是要去做。我只是要成为我想成为的人。我要按照我想的方式行事。这就是我。
This is what I look like. This is what I'm doing. And, you know, nobody else's opinions are going to be a factor. They just don't matter. So rule four is very similar. It kind of falls onto the same category. It's about watering your own grass. And I know we just kind of spoke about that, so I'll keep it brief.
这就是我的样子。这就是我在做的事。而且，你知道的，其他任何人的意见都不会成为一个因素。它们根本不重要。所以第四条规则非常相似。它差不多属于同一类别。它是关于浇灌你自己的草坪。我知道我们刚刚已经谈过这个了，所以我会长话短说。
I think a lot of the time we get stuck in the comparison spiral because there is something that we are unhappy or secure about. And so when we look at somebody else's life, the fact that they do have the thing that we don't makes us feel worse and makes us experience a level of cognitive dissidents, right? Either we can tear somebody else down and therefore elevate our own way of doing things or we can feel worse about ourselves. what option off the top of your head do you think we're most likely to take? Obviously option A, because that is what protects our ego. That is what, you know, what protects our brain from feeling rejected, from feeling less than, from feeling hurt. So it's the path that keeps us safest. But knocking somebody else down is a really unhealthy defense mechanism.
我认为很多时候我们陷入比较的漩涡，是因为我们对某事感到不快乐或不安全。因此，当我们看到别人的生活时，他们确实拥有我们所没有的东西这一事实让我们感觉更糟，并让我们经历了一种认知失调，对吧？要么我们可以贬低别人从而抬高我们自己的做法，要么我们可以对自己感觉更糟。你凭直觉想想，我们最有可能选择哪个选项？显然是选项A，因为那能保护我们的自我。那就是，你知道的，保护我们的脑免于感到被拒绝、感到低人一等、感到受伤。所以这是最安全的道路。但贬低别人是一种非常不健康的防御机制。
Instead, I think that we should respond as your ideal self would. by seeing somebody else's successes, seeing their beautiful, amazing life, and deciding you can also experience that joy by doing something that's good for you. You know, if you see someone at a music festival or overseas or like surrounded by all of their amazing friends on the weekend, you can be sour about it,
相反，我认为我们应该像理想中的自己那样做出反应。通过看到别人的成功，看到他们美丽、惊人的生活，并决定你也可以通过做对你有益的事情来体验那种快乐。你知道，如果你看到有人在音乐节上，或者在海外，或者在周末被他们所有了不起的朋友环绕，你可以对此感到酸溜溜的，
and that is, of course, our natural inclination, or you can go and do something that you also enjoy instead of feeling miserable or weakened. When you fixate on what you don't have, you let it shape your life and you let it have power. And it makes you feel like you're quite powerless. You don't have agency over what's happening because you're seeing this other person who has everything that you want,
当然，这是我们的自然倾向，或者你可以去做一些你同样喜欢的事情，而不是让自己感到痛苦或虚弱。当你专注于你没有的东西时，你让它塑造了你的生活，你让它拥有了力量。这让你觉得你相当无能为力。你对正在发生的事情没有自主权，因为你看到这个拥有你想要的一切的另一个人，
who has all the friends, who has the job, who has the clothes. And you think that you can't have that as well. And so that makes you quite frustrated and insecure and it makes you resent them. But when you water your own grass, when you shift back to what is going to make you happy, when you nurture your friendships, when you build your career, when you go outside and move your body, when you prioritize doing fun things on your weekends, you no longer feel threatened by what somebody else has because you realize that you can also create that life for yourself. So this brings me to our final fifth rule using comparison as a motivator rather than as a means to tear yourself down.
拥有所有的朋友，拥有工作，拥有衣服。而你认为你不可能也拥有那些。所以这让你感到相当沮丧和不安全，并让你对他们心生怨恨。但是，当你浇灌自己的草坪，当你重新把重点放在会让你快乐的事情上，当你滋养你的友谊，当你建立你的职业生涯，当你走到户外活动你的身体，当你优先在周末做有趣的事情时，你就不再会因为别人拥有什么而感到受到威胁，因为你意识到你也可以为自己创造那种生活。这就引出了我们的最后第五条规则：将比较作为一种动力，而不是作为贬低自己的手段。
So something that we haven't spoken about yet is this distinction between upward and downward social comparison. So downward social comparison involves comparing oneself to others who are perceived as less fortunate or less successful as a way of boosting our own sense of self-esteem and providing almost a sense of relief. that we're better than this person, that when we are compared, we'll come out on top. It's honestly often unconscious and very shallow, and it gives us an immediate sense of satisfaction, but at the expense of somebody else, and it's going to fade away pretty quickly. This is the kind of social comparison that we engage in for self-enhancement's sake. On the other hand, upward social comparison involves comparing ourselves to those who we think are more successful or superior, quote unquote, in a particular domain, either because they are more successful, they're more attractive, they have a greater status, they have more money. This type of comparison is often what leads to feelings of inadequacy and envy, and it's really on the rise.
所以我们还没谈过的一点是向上社交比较和向下社交比较的区别。向下社交比较是指将自己与那些被认为不如自己幸运或不如自己成功的人进行比较，以此来提升我们自己的自尊心，并带来一种我们比这个人更好、在比较中会胜出的解脱感。说实话，这种比较通常是无意识的、非常肤浅的，它能给我们带来即时的满足感，但代价是建立在别人的痛苦之上，而且这种感觉会很快消逝。这就是我们为了自我提升而进行的社会比较。另一方面，向上社交比较是指我们将自己与那些在某个领域我们认为更成功或更优秀（所谓的人生赢家）的人进行比较，无论是因为他们更成功、更有吸引力、地位更高、还是更有钱。这种比较往往会导致无力感和嫉妒心，而且它确实在不断增加。
Upward Social Comparison is a lot more common. There's a few reasons why. Perhaps it's this fascination with like celebrity culture, the rise in like idolization of people who are very, very successful, and increasing competitiveness in our society. But Upward Social Comparison can also be very useful. It's a very powerful source of motivation. Think about it.
向上社交比较要常见得多。原因有几个。也许是因为对名人文化的痴迷，对那些非常非常成功的人的偶像化现象的增加，以及我们社会日益加剧的竞争力。但向上社交比较也非常有用。它是一种非常强大的动力源泉。想想看。
If you see somebody who has something that you want, that just serves as confirmation that this goal you have, this life, this achievement is possible. And instead of feeling bitter that you don't have it yet, you now have something to strive towards. You have somebody to learn from, to replicate, you have a vision for your future self. I think that this strategy is about turning the part of you that naturally wants to be jealous into someone who wants to feel inspired, who is a cheerleader for others. So in one study they found that when people were asked to speak about someone they admire in a positive light, in the days and even weeks afterwards, they became more productive and focused. Compared to the people who were asked to criticize people that they admired, they actually became less disciplined. In another kind of domain and other study, they wanted to look at this in regards to people who are recovering from eating disorders.
如果你看到有人拥有你想要的东西，这正好证明了你的这个目标、这种生活、这种成就是可能的。你不会因为自己还没有得到它而感到痛苦，而是有了一个为之奋斗的方向。你有了可以学习、效仿的对象，有了对未来自己的愿景。我认为这个策略的关键在于，将你内心那个天生想要嫉妒的部分，变成一个想要感到备受鼓舞、愿意为他人欢呼的人。因此在一项研究中，他们发现当人们被要求以积极的眼光谈论他们钦佩的人时，在接下来的几天甚至几周里，他们的工作效率更高，也更专注。相比之下，那些被要求批评他们钦佩的人的受试者，他们的自律性实际上变差了。在另一个领域和另一项研究中，他们希望从进食障碍康复者的角度来研究这个问题。
and the researchers found that the comparison effect was actually quite positive when people were exposed to individuals who were further along in their recovery journey because it was kind of driving self-improvement, especially amongst people who are particularly competitive, right? Obviously, we need to proceed with caution, especially in the case of a serious mental health condition that has a very high rate of relapse. But at the core of both of these studies is this method. that you can use your desire to compare to motivate you. You can use your desire to make yourself feel bad by looking at what somebody else has. You can use that as a catalyst to change yourself
研究人员发现，当人们接触到那些在康复之路上走得更远的人时，比较效应实际上是相当积极的，因为这在某种程度上推动了自我完善，特别是在那些好胜心强的人当中，对吧？显然，我们需要谨慎行事，尤其是在面对复发率极高的严重心理健康问题时。但这两项研究的核心都是这种方法，你可以利用你的比较欲来激励自己。你可以利用那种通过看着别人拥有什么而让自己感到难受的心理。你可以将其作为改变自己和生活的催化剂。
and your own life. I've seen this personally. I think about this a lot when I think about like running content that I see on Instagram. I'm really getting back into running recently. It's something I used to love doing. I just kind of fell off the bandwagon. And I've been, of course, my algorithm has adjusted to this new interest. And it keeps showing me all these videos of people who are doing like, they are sinking miles. They were doing half marathons before they go to work in the morning and full marathons on weekends. And for a while, it actually left me feeling quite disappointed in myself. I kept being like, well, why am I not at that level? Why do I not have what they have? And I could unfollow.
以及你自己的生活。我亲身经历过这一点。每当我看到Instagram上的跑步内容时，我就会经常这样想。我最近真的很想重新开始跑步。这是我以前很喜欢做的事情。我只是有点半途而废了。当然，我的算法也适应了这个新兴趣。它一直给我推荐各种视频，里面的人在疯狂刷里程。他们在早上去上班前跑半程马拉松，周末跑全程马拉松。有一段时间，这确实让我对自己的现状感到很失望。我一直在想，为什么我达不到那个水平？为什么我没有他们拥有的东西？我本可以取消关注。
I could say, like, well, if I was their size, if I'd been doing it for this long, I could do that as well. Oh, like they just, they're not working as hard as I am. So they have more time for this. I could say that. I could be in this kind of like sulky mindset. But what it would mean is that I would miss out on so many tips, so much inspiration, so much growth. Because they're doing the thing that I want to do. They're proof that I can get where I want to go.
我可以说，好吧，如果我是他们的体型，如果我也坚持了这么久，我也可以做到。或者觉得，他们只是没有我努力。所以他们有更多的时间做这个。我大可以这么说。我可以陷入这种闷闷不乐的心态。但这意味着我将错失太多的技巧、太多的灵感、太多的成长。因为他们在做我想做的事情。他们证明了我可以到达我想去的地方。
So instead of looking at somebody else and feeling bad because you're not squaring up to what they have, just see it as a target. See it as confirmation that everything you want in your life is possible because they've done it. So I want to give you two final speed round tips. Firstly, despite all that we've talked about, sometimes we do still find ourselves feeling really shit about where we're at and thinking that we are behind, that we are failing, that we aren't. who we want to be, everyone else is better than us. You know, you get the picture. In those moments, I want you to immediately counteract that thought by saying five things that you're good at, or listing five things that you've accomplished this past week, this past month in your life.
所以，不要看着别人然后因为自己达不到他们的水平而感到难受，而是要把这看作一个目标。把它当作一种确信：你生活中想要的一切都是可能的，因为他们已经做到了。所以我最后想给大家两个快速连珠炮式的建议。首先，尽管我们讨论了这么多，有时我们仍然会对自己目前的处境感到非常糟糕，觉得我们落后了，我们在失败，我们不是我们想成为的那种人，其他每个人都比我们好。你知道那种感觉。在那些时刻，我希望你立刻通过说出五件你擅长的事情，或者列出过去一周、过去一个月里你所取得的五项成就来反驳这种想法。
You don't need to be humble. You have done amazing things. You've probably done a lot of really cool things. And when you hide them from yourself, when you spend too much time being self-deprecating or trying not to seem egotistical. Sometimes it's easy to forget. So when we see somebody else who is willing to be open about their accomplishments, we kind of forget that we might also be at that level. We're just not as willing to talk openly about it. Finally, remember that the person you're comparing yourself to
你不需要谦虚。你已经做得很棒了。你可能已经做成了很多非常酷的事情。当你对自己隐瞒这些时，当你花太多时间自嘲或试图让自己看起来不那么自负时。有时人们很容易忘记。所以当我们看到另一个人愿意公开谈论他们的成就时，我们就会有点忘记我们其实也可能达到了那个水平。我们只是没有那么愿意公开谈论它。最后，请记住，那个你正在与之进行比较的人
is probably doing the exact same thing to somebody else. There is somebody in their mind who is better than them. They are comparing themselves to that person. probably right now. That person may even be you. You have no idea what is going on internally in somebody else's mind. We often think we're the only person with doubts, with insecurity, when it actually is one of the most universal parts about being human. But when we get stuck in our heads and don't filter our experience through the lens of our humanity, it makes us feel more shame for something that is so normal. I want to remind you, there is not a person out there
可能正在对其他人做着完全相同的事情。在他们的脑海里，有那么一个人比他们更优秀。他们正在和那个人作比较。可能就在此刻。那个人甚至可能就是你。你根本不知道别人内心深处在想什么。我们总以为自己是唯一一个充满怀疑、没有安全感的人，而实际上，这是人性中最普遍的部分之一。但当我们陷入自己的思维中，没有透过人性的镜头去过滤我们的经历时，它会让我们为一件如此正常的事情感到更多的羞耻。我想提醒你，没有哪个人
there who does not have the same thoughts that you are having now. And if that person does exist, either they, like, came out of the womb at, like, the peak of spiritual enlightenment, or there is something very psychologically wrong with that person. Because what our social comparison stems from is an awareness of others and an awareness of where they're out in their lives, what they're doing. And that awareness is important for so many other things in our life, right? It's important for empathy.
没有产生过你现在正在经历的想法。如果真有这样的人，要么他就像是刚出娘胎就达到了精神觉醒的巅峰，要么就是他在心理上有很大的毛病。因为我们的社会比较源于对他人以及对他们生活现状、他们所作所为的觉察。这种觉察对于我们生活中的许多其他事情都很重要，对吧？它对同理心很重要。
it's important for connection, for inspiration. It's like two sides of the same coin, right? Being more socially conscious comes with a lot of perks, but it also means that we can be more self-conscious. So we have to learn how to treat it correctly. We have to learn to use it for its advantages and to not use it as a form of self-sabotage or a form of self-destruction whereby the only time we compare ourselves to others is just to make ourselves feel worse. You are a cool person. You are an interesting person. You are an intelligent, successful, beautiful person in your own right.
它对于建立联系、获取灵感都很重要。这就像同一枚硬币的两面，对吧？更有社会意识会带来很多好处，但也意味着我们可能会变得更自我意识过剩。所以我们必须学会如何正确对待它。我们必须学会利用它的优势，而不是把它当作自我破坏或自我毁灭的形式，导致我们与他人比较的唯一目的就是让自己感觉更糟。你是一个很酷的人。你是一个有趣的人。就你自身而言，你是一个聪明、成功、美丽的人。
So don't let what somebody else has, their beauty, their achievements, their cool factor, their job, whatever it is. Remember, those things are not mutually exclusive. You can both be those things. It doesn't detract from everything that you have. I just want to finish on that reminder. So I really hope that you have enjoyed this episode. Thank you for putting up with my voice today. I'm a little bit sick. So hopefully it wasn't too grading. But, you know, I just felt that this episode needed to be done. I feel like social comparison is such a curse that we manage in our 20s. But it's like a curse that we don't need to suffer through because there are so many solutions. And it really does come down to how we think about it, right? Whether we think about it as something that is meant to harm us and something that is meant to make us feel bad or something that can really ignore. our sense of purpose and be inspirational and does come from a deep like recognition and connection
所以不要让别人拥有的东西，他们的美貌、他们的成就、他们的酷劲、他们的工作，无论是什么，定义了你。请记住，这些事情并不是互斥的。你可以同时拥有这些品质。它不会减损你所拥有的这一切。我只想以这个提醒作为结束。所以，我真心希望你们喜欢这一集。谢谢你们今天包容我的声音。我有点生病了。所以希望声音没有那么刺耳。但是，你知道，我只是觉得这一集是非做不可。我觉得社会比较是我们二十多岁时不得不应付的一个诅咒。但这是一个我们不需要饱受折磨的诅咒，因为有那么多的解决方案。这真的归结于我们如何看待它，对吧？是我们把它看作是一种旨在伤害我们、让我们感觉糟糕的事情，还是一种能够真正激发我们的目标感、具有启发性、并且源于对他人深切的认可和联系的事情
with others. So thank you so much for listening. I hope that you got something from this episode. If there is somebody who needs to hear it, please feel free to share it with them. And make sure you're following along on Spotify, Apple Podcasts, wherever you're listening so that you know when new episodes go up. As always, if you have an episode suggestion, Firstly, make sure we haven't done it. You can just search it wherever you are looking, the keywords, or shoot me a DM on Instagram, and I'll point you in the right direction. Otherwise, give us a suggestion.
非常感谢你们的收听。我希望你们能从这一集里有所收获。如果有人需要听听这个，请随时分享给他们。请确保在Spotify、Apple Podcasts或你收听的任何平台上关注我们，这样你就不会错过新的一集。一如既往，如果你对节目有什么建议，首先，请确保我们还没做过这个主题。你可以在你使用的平台上搜索关键词，或者在Instagram上给我发私信，我会为你指明方向。否则，给我们提个建议吧。
We would love to hear from you. We would love to know what you want us to speak about. When it comes to our attorneys, when it comes to psychology, there is so much to be said. So thank you again for listening. Until next time, be kind to yourself. Be gentle. Stay safe. And we'll see you back next week.
我们很期待听到你的声音。我们很想知道你想让我们聊些什么话题。谈到我们的二十岁，谈到心理学，有太多的话题可以探讨了。再次感谢大家的收听。下次见之前，对自己好一点。温柔一点。保持安全。我们下周再见。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor?
嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难抉择》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个空间专门探讨黑人的心路历程，进行在其他地方绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人随身带着一副盔甲？
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
它在向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着仅仅因为你有这种能力，你就必须这样去做。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难抉择》。在2023年，“钻石单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mianini. My mind was blown.
但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你伪造了这个特定的检测结果两次对吧？我伪造了一次检测。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·米安尼尼。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困之爱》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the end. other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed.
在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建设复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会迎来彼岸
I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your grower. Girlfriends. Listen to the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即TWO percent，在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的直觉。闺蜜们。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《闺蜜：相信我，宝贝》。这是一个IHeart播客。